well we've been really focusing on this
uh ukrainian offensive in the northeast
because uh initially it appears that it
is one of the biggest uh military
counter offenses in europe uh since
world war ii and it's been remarkable at
how fast the ukrainians have been able
to retake land and towns in the
northeast with this offensive that we
will continue to watch closely but while
we are watching that further to the
south at europe's biggest nuclear plant
the zapariza nuclear plant that is in
ukrainian territory but has been
controlled by russian forces for months
now
the ukrainian uh ukrainian nuclear
agency is informing us now that they
have shut down that power plant shut
down the power supply there let me
explain what they essentially have done
is in the middle of the night the the
sixth reactor lost external power due to
shelling early on sunday morning the
ukrainian operators decided to
intentionally for safety reasons shut
down that sixth uh
nuclear generator after they were able
to restore external power it's a process
called islanding
and what they are doing in the short
term it's to to decrease the risk of an
unintentional nuclear accident but in
the long term it is still very
precarious because it is not a process
uh that is normally used in a in a
normal situation it is normally used
only in emergencies so moving forward
should the the nuclear power plant in
zapposia need more power
besides the internal power that they
have now to shut down the systems they
would have to do that with diesel
generators that is clearly not an ideal
situation but they felt they needed to
essentially shut down the nuclear power
plant for safety reasons so as we focus
on the fighting in the northeast and the
south still uh the zaparisia power plant
situation there is still in a very very
dangerous position for the update
gabriel elizondo live in ukraine's
capital kiev
now ukraine's president says winter
could be a turning point for reclaiming
ukrainian territory from russian troops
but vladimir zelensky insists to achieve
those goals more weapons and financial
support are needed
there are 90 days ahead which will
decide more than 30 years of ukraine's
independence 90 days will decide more
than all the years of the existence of
the european union winter will determine
our future and what the risks are
well let's speak now to maximilian hess
who's a fellow in the eurasia program at
the foreign policy research institute
he's joining us from london very good to
have you with us on al jazeera uh what
are your thoughts first about these
remarkable advances by the ukrainians
how do you think they've been able to
achieve these breakthroughs so quickly
well thank you for having me the
ukrainians have credited their own
counter-offensive that they announced at
the end of august in the gherson region
in the south they have said that this
has distracted russian forces and caused
russia to have to regroup and position a
number of its most capable and most
technically advanced units down there
which then enabled them to launch this
counter-offensive uh southeast of
kharkiv and just northwest of the main
fighting in the donetsk region as well
the russian telegram community this
group of russian bloggers who often
travel alongside the russian military
and promote it uh had warned of this
however and have been quite apoplectic
and complaining about it so it's led not
only to a battlefield victory but a
major propaganda victory right i was
going to ask you how damaging is this
for for putin inside russia if russians
get to see this it's it's difficult to
see how he's going to spin this
i think what the ukrainians have really
been fighting for on the battlefield for
quite some time now is ensuring that
whatever victory putin may achieve in
eastern ukraine in terms of taking more
territory that it's a pyrrhic victory
that it's one that ultimately has uh
major costs for him and undermines his
governance in the long term this
backlash that we've seen in this
denouncement from these russian
right-wing groups is exactly that which
they've been hoping to lay the
groundwork for now the russian far right
these russian nationalist groups that
have been the ones who've really been
carping about the military withdrawals
they are not politically unified and
where they are it is very heavily
controlled by the kremlin so it remains
to be seen whether that backlash method
method sizes into something but it
certainly feel and quite unprecedented
in the level that we've seen it how
might moscow respond now you think they
have a limited military pool what plans
do you think are being considered or are
going to be put in place to respond to
to these advances
well sadly in relation to a number of
other ukrainian military successes or
announcements of new initiatives for
example in the question the other week
the russians have then unleashed a
barrage of missile strikes on ukrainian
cities and populated centers so that's a
real concern for for the immediate
future that i think people have to be
worried about from khadki all the way to
the west of ukraine militarily to retake
the initiatives uh in ukraine it looks
like the russians are already sending
more troops uh down to the front there
there are areas where they've had more
successes in the city of baku than its
surroundings uh in northeastern donetsk
oblast so this
uh major advance with ukrainians is a
turning point but the russians do still
have the capability to um really put
pressure on the ukrainians and other
points in the front and will likely
launch their own counter-attack in that
area maximilian we also the atrocities
in bucha are you concerned should we be
concerned that such atrocities could
happen again
as the russians withdraw from territory
that they occupied
you know the the russian
atrocities that we saw there largely
came during the occupation though of
course there were even further attempts
to clean up their tracks as they
withdrew and i think that's a real
concern for the ukrainians also the
looting of industrial property
in the area so yes those are sadly real
concerns as i said the the most
immediate one right now is the russians
have precedent for major uh
rocket strikes on urban areas targeting
civilian populations yeah in terms of of
talks and negotiations
we're not there yet of course but what
would ukraine accept if there were to be
any peace negotiations or do you feel
that ukraine doesn't have to make a deal
now that they've made these advances and
are regaining some of their territory
lost
i don't think there's the political will
on either side right now for renewed
negotiations in ukraine if russia came
and offered them a full withdrawal to
the lines before uh the 24th of february
that
may get them interested but but putin
and his regime have sown no intention of
making that offer uh after this setback
or after previous ones so sadly i think
the ball is still really in the court of
what will it take to get putin to change
his military aims and to recognize that
all that he had hoped to achieve in
february is not only impossible but that
he's getting further and further away
from it as time goes on because any such
move would have major domestic political
ramifications within russia i don't
think we should be expecting it in the
immediate future
that is i certainly hope that
the russian army and the kremlin comes
to that realization thank you so much
for talking to us thank you for insight
maximilian hess from the foreign policy
research institute in london
[Music]